top for some react ception we are going
to watch from corridor crew a video that
they put out in November of 2019 we made
Star Wars r-rated I did see on my own
time the Marvel R rated one which was
pretty cool
I haven't seen this one yet this is a
good friend David not the whole movie
no that'd be smart oh no they're going
to mollis that creature aren't they may
not know about this
[Laughter]
yeah
there are a lot of disparate sponsor
segments people just skip this go past
the counter maybe the counter helps
people realize how short the ad is and
they reverse psychology stay
it's delightful
how many cameramen they got working
really to storm ever shooting out do you
see the Kira there's no one guy who's
stealing the kids beginning it's all
shot up other eye police I want to first
off not nearly enough place I've been
fired so I win that cranky believes a
perfectly matched my lasers movie using
andrew kramer's saver plugin
Mandy basically went and made the best
laser slash lightsaber plugin for After
Effects what video
what holes in it sounds at these lasers
as well as like clothing but to yellow
you to do something he's gonna what
charger put this ah yes
[Laughter]
so enjoying this way too so gross thing
that you add is distinct now this is an
example of using just nothing but
existing video files that I already had
that I can just throw in there out cards
but Sam over there is actually working
on a custom blood simulation for his
shot and that'll be one of a kind I want
to see that
trying new techniques we know that home
alone oh my goodness
so he's falling so fast that his body
combusts into the million little pieces
if you actually watch the scene where he
threatens the babies with the lightsaber
it immediately cuts to Padme apartment
so we took that Q this is probably where
he's gonna land basically I'm gonna have
the youngling be on the lane explode
into pieces so the way I want to do that
is using a fluid simulation so in order
to make a fluid simulation this is my
little environment here so rather than
actually simulate something flowing down
exploding but I basically just have the
body at the glass and I'm using this the
source that's what is going to emit but
I got all this fluid here I'm basically
just I just just go from this moment
because if something's falling from that
high velocity it's gonna go all over the
place be sure and I'm just telling the
fluid hey fluid I want you to have a lot
of friction you know
a mesh around them determines these
particles that doesn't fascinating Wow
interesting
one of those cool advances techniques
I've never been asked to look at before
called making a wedding mat this is
really good for splatters and stains the
trail of the fluid that follows
something like this sponge I just wiped
it on the wall it would leave a wet
trail behind so that's the name of what
map these particles now are painting
residuals smearing of lexingto running
down the glass
so we would see
[Music]
[Music]
oh there goes your obi-wan show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
now not the young lady here we go
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes I hope my clunky
[Music]
was well done delay I think that's what
George Lucas ought to have done going
back in the sea giing the deal the
original movies add blood and guts I
love that final Yoda bit it's funny how
far an unnecessary censorship can take
you just a little bit of a blur a little
bit of green in the background of that
blur and you got big Yoda schlong
reminded me even though this predates my
stick and reminded me of them my stick
battle it dummy the idea of Star Wars
being r-rated where it could possibly go
I think the theory with the lasers is
that the Laser cauterizes the wound oh
right yeah
super heat yeah so this video doesn't
make any sense corners yeah where's your
physics man I understand what you're
doing for what they added on to it it
didn't make me can kind of want to see
like a full rated R version that I you
know Star Wars is never gonna go down
that path even with something like rogue
one which I think they could do whatever
effects they did here for rogue one and
make an r-rated version of that
considering sort of the the tone of that
and the violence that's in there as well
I was more impressed with the little or
things that they did here like the force
choking when the blood vessels are
coming out eyeballs trying to bleed like
their eyes are popping out of their head
I found that really impressive it's just
like a little nugget of a physics detail
that I think would be more effective
that's why Tarantino had to choke Diane
Kruger a nun glorious bastard so you can
get the veins in the eyes popping out a
Star Wars needs to do that I'm surprised
they never have done something to
enhance that though when you think about
especially with the choke because no
actor dude whoa are you okay no right
very believable oh my god when someone
is being choked they do start to have
these you know like the blood vessels do
start to show their face turning red or
purple yeah I think that wouldn't put
you an r-rated I mean the would the
degree they did to here yeah but I think
they could borrow a little bit of notes
from this corridor video of how to
enhance like certain little elements
like that but I did
a lot of what they did I think the
Topher Grace cut of the prequels could
be great if he just included that one
moment of jar jar's head exploding and
that explains my jar jar's not in the
rest of the Topher Grace Code the
prequels viola yeah actually that would
be perfect just cut it right in I mean
it like it's a fan edit anyway so if you
just take this footage I like that this
ran a gamut between like simple effects
and then more complicated ones like you
started out with the one Jedi guy
getting shot up by the clone troopers
and it's like I'm just gonna add like a
wound and a blood splat and with the
motion blur it looks pretty much like an
eye socket hole and then you know going
over to the more complicated I'm trying
a technique I've never tried before with
the whole kid exploding against the gas
and I appreciated those little nuances
they left in the scene tab made turns
around and just like looks at the blood
dripping down and begins to cry just
totally recontextualizes the scene and
no matter how depressed this heart and
Padme looks Korra Cruz is cracking up I
thought it was really impressive how
they were able to it's something that
might seem very little but replacing the
lightsaber and Hannigan's hand in that
moment when the young lean does ask him
like what are we gonna do Master
Skywalker replaced with the height
button you know that little thing
because that lightsaber is taking up a
good chunk of the screen and then what
they when they take out the lifesaver
app they have to fill in the rest hain't
all that out and I'm sure that's like
simple for them but to me I find that
really impressive where you don't even
notice any of that maybe because my eye
was just immediately drawn to the hight
button because I was expecting a
lightsaber but the way they do fill in
the gaps where the lightsaber should be
I think is a really impressive trait
that they they can do with all these
videos yeah man they bring a lot of
personality with them I feel like there
should just be a corridor like instead
of the new George Lucas cut they should
just do a corridor cut I like when they
do cut around to them just hanging out
reviewing the footage that they've done
especially after they presented all of
it and they were just chit-chatting
about all they accomplished and the guy
the guy who's like recorded them as if
it's like a documentary or something
like that I wonder what it is like
hanging out with all them in that studio
because they're clearly very very
hard-working people and are very smart
so I gotta imagine that when you're a
bunch of people working at a computer
it's probably just really quiet there a
lot of yeah like the way the foot
makes it look like is that they're just
hanging out and laughing all the time
and maybe they are no that's all CG from
my perspective though I was under the
impression that when they're working
it's just a bunch of people looking at a
computer and they're not really talking
to each other for most of the day that's
usually how it goes
yeah that's how it is here everything
pretty much yeah two of us divide up and
click-click click-click but you know
neither of us knows after-effects yet so
we can't we should go back and redo all
our sketches r-rated yeah let's add in
cut out all the effects Kyle Luhrmann
did for us yes I do think that one day
Star Wars should attempt to do something
that's r-rated you see what they've been
doing with making some arbiter
properties it's been working out pretty
well for them even though the whole
Marvel Fox they'll happen there what
there's Deadpool and there was Logan
like Star Wars seems to be the one
franchise that I can't see ever going or
I just can't fathom them actually
willing to do that well yeah I mean you
look at the original movies and they are
so I mean you know there's peril and
there is war but there's that your leads
are so plucky and gung-ho you know yeah
but when you do movies like rogue one I
feel like those like standalone films
could benefit off of having a bit of an
r-rated flair to it even if they do
something like teeners on our rating but
doesn't quite hit there I think that
would be something people would really
want to tune in for the one franchise
where I just can't ever see them
actually going down that route but if
they did I think a lot of people would
want to go check it out the first
r-rated Star Wars film that would be
pretty sweet like a standard you just do
a standalone you know I think everybody
would go see that one just for the sheer
question mark of the whole thing like no
matter if you're a die-hard fan I hate
what's been good like everyone would be
like I gotta see what this thing a super
sexual super violent it's gonna say yeah
it's not just the violence till you find
out what sex is like in the galaxy you
find out what dysfunctional
relationships are like in the galaxy you
know get a lot of swearing in there have
it be like a Tarantino movie and sort of
Star Trek he should do Star Wars but
then a set of swear words
you mean you swear words but use you
know galactic swear words you know
something like that
yeah give glory alright well if you
haven't done so already subscribe to
corridor crew you can subscribe to us
click our notification mail David Gandy
thank you for requesting this dude David
I know you're a huge Star Wars nut you
went to galaxy's edge last year now they
open up rise of the resistance I hope
you get a chance to go back there
lead the rebellion and conquering the
first order perfect guy for it you
totally got those leadership qualities
that are waiting to be awakened out of
you
the force needs to be awakened within
you one day dude don't worry I will
watch Star Wars rebels and when I say
one day maybe 10 years from now when
people stop asking me to watch it when
the pressures gone same thing with Clone
Wars but in the meantime thank you for
being part of our patreon page buddy and
thanks for always sending us over some
awesome videos to check out further
educating our my if you do become an
intergalactic general of some kind make
sure you serenade your troops with your
guitar and your martial arts skills make
some kind of interpretive dance because
we don't see the artistic world of Star
Wars and you could bring that to life I
very good thanks